instaurer un droit au revenu minimum est
une innovation d'une portée considérable
1988 michel rocard premier ministre
socialiste un store rmi une promesse de
campagne de françois mitterrand dans un
contexte social tendu
je n'ai pas digne de notre passé n'est
concevable pour notre avenir que tant de
gens survivent dans la misère la misère
car dans les années 80 la france est
confrontée au phénomène des nouveaux
pauvres entre 1980 et 1988
le taux de chômage en france est passé
de 5% à 8% alors chose rare le revenu
minimum d'insertion et votés à
l'unanimité
il y as consensus tout le monde est
d'accord pour voter le texte y compris
le rpr ce qui a permis de convaincre la
droite c'est le i de rmi autrement dit
la volonté d'insertion de ces chômeurs
en fin de droits car c'était bien ça à
l'enjeu faire revenir sur le chemin du
travail des chômeurs de longue durée
j'ai vu que j'étais j'ai servent encore
à quelque chose que j'étais pas nul que
j'étais pas uniquement une femme arista
la maison à élever des gosses non je
peux quand même travailler c'est revoir
que je suis capable de faire quelque
chose et puis de deux meurtres avec
d'autres personnes puis çà çà çà çà
change vraiment ça
mais ce qui devait être une mesure
transitoire permettant au chômeur de
revenir dans le monde du travail est
devenue pérenne
dix ans après l'instauration du rmi
michel rocard dresser un bilan
il est un lieu où céline catastrophe
c'est que le chômage a continué à
augmenter a souvent là le rmi au lieu
d'être le traitement d'un flux permanent
renouveler mémé est stable en quantité
de chômeurs il est le traitement d'un
stock de gens en constante augmentation
il n'a pas été fait pour ça il ne peut
pas tenir
[Musique]
en 2008 20 ans après son instauration le
rmi laisse place du rsa aujourd'hui un
million huit cent mille personnes
touchent sa prestation
[Musique]